the head coach of the Seattle Seahawks
Pete Carroll kind enough to call in to
the program right here in Indianapolis
how you been coach good what's going on
rich how you doing it's been too
it's been too long so you're the perfect
guest to have this conversation with
with everybody talking about Kyler
Murray and his height and his weight and
his hand size and the comparison to
Russell Wilson I'm wondering how
important was all of that when you were
making that evaluation back in the day
of your current quarterback well was
certainly part of the conversation and
in knowing that you know we were going
against some of the traditional numbers
and stuff like that that it was it was
interesting you know for us to look at
it you know Russell in particular you
know it had done everything he needed to
see player wise we just had to kind of
get over the hump on you know kind of
the status quo thinking and and we were
able to do that we saw an incredible
player enter the league well I mean in
terms of status quo thinking what was
that just your own I guess
thoughts on what the league had been was
it somebody else and I'm just fascinated
by the conversation that might have been
taking place yeah I don't think you know
I was the best cool I think that that
was kind of constructed by you know
years of you know coaches and and
onlookers and all that thinking that you
got to be tall and you got to be the
long guys and you got to be that you
know that pocket guy and all that kind
of stuff you know it even always been a
statement about about mobile
quarterbacks not being able to you know
be championship and all that and so the
fact that you know we got we got a
chance to see Russ and if we've seen him
blossom and be such a big factor in the
league I think it changes thinking you
know I and I think it's to the benefit
of anybody that's come along after him
and there aren't very many guys you know
that they're smaller guys in height and
all that but we got one coming up this
time
no I know it's obvious and I do you
think because I guess you just led me to
my next question do you think that
Russell's success and what you have
shown that you can do with him has led
to a changing of the guard where the
status quo has now changed that you were
kind of on the beginning
part of that curve well you know which I
don't know that it has but if it hasn't
I think you guys are crazy because you
know as is shown you know the it doesn't
it wasn't a factor you know now
Russell's an extraordinary player - you
know maybe we don't want in the cycle
you know that can do it I don't know but
he certainly has shown you know and then
we you know skip don't forget that Drew
Brees is just a little bit taller than
Russell so there are some guys that have
really done it in recent times and shown
but I would I'll be surprised that we
don't see an impact you know on the
decision-making of teams with the new
guy coming up and based on what they've
seen Russell do Pete Carroll here on the
Rich Eisen show you just stepped away
from the podium and some of the news
that broke is Doug Baldwin having
surgeries plural after the season what
what what did he in fact have well he
had some work done they weren't like
reconstructive surgeries but there was
just stuff to help him rehab and you
know help the process was getting strong
and getting right again incredible
incredible competitor he's been you know
and he has proven it year in and year
out of this toughness and and all of
that and so this is just a stage he's
getting through here to get himself as
well as you can possibly get and get
ready okay and where do you stand
coach Pete Carroll here on the show
where do you stand on the competition
committee conversation that's being had
here on changing replay in some way to
prevent what happened at the end of the
NFC Championship game from ever
happening again
well yeah first off you know which way
back historically I didn't I wasn't a
big fan of replay and I've had to grow
along with it like you know we all have
and we've seen it continue to improve I
think over the years and I think we need
to keep improving it and we need to keep
endeavoring to make it better and make
it better in bone all that and I there's
some suggestions this year that have
come up that are going to be really
worthy of consideration you know and
it's always been a very very difficult
call with the you know the it's on
defense of
senseless players it happened so fast
and didn't know whether contact made you
know to the head area that had neck area
or was it just underneath that of what
wasn't with the shoulder or wasn't with
the helmet that just happened so fast
that I think that in that regard we
played could certainly assist the
decision-making and it just you know
that happened to be a you know factor in
the in the one big playoff games of
course but that that's just in case that
s have been something talked about Wow I
know this talk about pass interference
I'm about that one you know I that's
that's still so subjective I think that
she just let the coaches keep griping
about it on the sidelines and and figure
that one out to do it right but there
are some good choices in here that might
you know might change our thinking and
if it can help the game and keep it safe
for let's do it why don't you like about
replay coach you don't like it you
dismiss old on no I like the flow the
game always I like the gameplay I always
like I know this doesn't sound right
because you see me hollering it guys on
the sidelines the officials know but I
always liked their ability to control
the game in and make their calls and
they're part of the game just as the
players are and they they have to make
subjective calls they got to do it
anyway I just always liked that part of
it keep the flow of the game going but
that I'm you know that's that's dinosaur
talk now so yeah you're on the cutting
edge you're the one who's looked at
Russell Wilson and say let's go draft
him what's going to Super Bowl with him
right I mean that I can't believe we all
have to keep it adapted and number one
okay look I know you got a lot of people
pulling at you I appreciated you hopping
on the phone line today and we'll chat
again soon you got it okay you got a
thanks Pete that's Pete Carroll right
there the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience